ron desantis is the governor of florida
the free state and he's doing
what no elected republican we're aware
of nationwide has done he's proposing a
new law that would
fine big tech companies for censoring
political candidates
companies that remove a candidate for
office would face a hundred thousand
dollars in fines
every day until the candidates access to
the tech platform is restored
additionally the law would require that
big tech companies give advanced notice
before they ban users
governor ron desantis joins us tonight
to explain this governor thanks so much
for coming on did we characterize that
correctly what this law would do
yeah and it's more than that i mean i
think we're going to do three different
uh things one is protect floridian's
data privacy from big tech which is a
huge issue
as you said protect big tech from
interfering in an election and that may
mean you dis
you de-platform a candidate you don't
like uh
two guesses as to which type of
candidate big tech wouldn't like
but it also means doing the algorithms
in a way that will suppress stories
or accelerate them to benefit a
candidate that's effectively an in-kind
contribution
and then the general protections for
de-platforming
users and what we're allowing people to
do is bring civil suits under the
florida deceptive and unfair
trade practices statute and anti-fraud
statute and also allowing the state
attorney general to do that as well
if big tech is not applying their terms
of service in a in a coherent and
principled way which
they almost never do so we think that
this is something that floridians want
protection from
and i think it'll end up being a really
good first step i mean there's always
been the question
what do you do about this i think a lot
of us have thought there was something
wrong for a long time
but to just sit back and hope it gets
better that clearly wasn't going to work
so
we're leading and i think it'll be good
no one has done anything this is the
first example of this that we have seen
in this country i know
in eastern europe it's been tried who is
opposed to this
we would love to know their names
well stay tuned tucker is this going to
be a big fight in the legislative
session
hopefully we'll be able to get a lot of
support i think most folks
do want protections for their privacy
and their data
i think most folks want protections from
being de-platform and it's not just
being banned from twitter or something
as we've seen these these companies can
act they can collude
they can deny you if you're a small
business of payment processing
the ability to use email and text so
what you go to a rally that they don't
like or you
engage in wrong think and all of a
sudden your flower
business is decapitated for for a month
because
they take action so i think we're go
we've gone down a dangerous path on this
this provides protections
for individual floridians and i think
it'll be very positively received but
buckle we're buckled up the tucker we
know that there's always fights over
these things
uh so stay tuned yeah i mean this really
does set the standard for the rest of
the country
it'll be fascinating to see who comes
out of the woodwork to
oppose it very quickly can if florida if
you get this through the legislature in
florida
will it have implications for the rest
of the country
i think it will because what we found
tucker is when florida leads and other
states start following
so i think you will see other
legislatures follow suit
but i also think it's just a situation
we're a very mobile society i mean
florida laws
may actually have uh an effect on folks
who who are
visiting here all the time so i think
it's going to be it's going to have an
effect one way or another beyond our
borders
maybe there's a reason people are moving
to florida just to guess governor
sanders i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you
thanks tucker